what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm going
to be reacting to a video that
one of my subscribers sent me and i'm
going to see
if i like it it's like a little playlist
um before i start do not forget to
subscribe to the channel and bring that
notification bell while you're at it
subscribe to their channels coastal
comedy network
um okay
did somebody order a sausage pizza hot
and ready
is that a little caesars line plus
that's a domino's box
whatever it's pizza
oh you can't pay with that but it'll be
13.53
i'm so confused it's a credit card
i bought a baby with a credit card cash
or i'll take another table
what does that mean is this a oh if a
pizza porno
happened in real life guys this is why
i don't get it i don't watch porn
i was so confused i was like why are
they acting weird
what you could have just left it on the
counter
what are you gonna do about it daddy
i had a tip for you but
i mean anymore
oh so you're gonna make me work for the
tip
[Music]
unfortunately mitch suffers from
erectile dysfunction
do you need some help or do you need to
uh there might be some confusion here i
thought i ordered pizza hut
and i'm pretty sure this is a pizza hut
anymore no silly
you ordered pizza oh
that makes a lot of sense i just wanted
a pizza though
humble hurt king what the [ __ ] what's up
with this laptop
and what about this light and who the
[ __ ] is this guy
oh yeah we'll just take a five
you scared off my sound guy from online
karate classes what am i supposed to do
now
pay for this pizza i can teach you
karate
okay can i wear a wig you can do
whatever you want
okay i'm trying to get a new phone i
came to the right place man
look at that galaxy okay one week
working at a t
versus one month look at that camera
space zoom it can wirelessly charge
other phones
and look at that design where are you
trying to sell me at
android right now yes android no
facetime green bubbles
green bubbles oh no i'm good bro i i
actually like getting [ __ ] bruh i'm
pulling that you get plenty of [ __ ]
with this
with that brick yes [ __ ] i'm cool nah
nah nah nah nah i'm cool
what kind of phone you got stop trying
to show me that
yeah i got a iphone 12 5 12.
okay look i'm just trying to get my
commissions man that's it
that's all i'm trying to get my
commission's come on all right now you
can get them
just not off of me bro i'm out of here i
thought you wanted a new phone not that
[ __ ]
hey bud could you help me out real quick
i i don't know i'm just trying to find
the right iphone case i don't know
iphone yeah i don't know what iphone
this is i'm not getting no iphone
that was getting android phone see this
android galaxy s8 what are you a caveman
i don't use this [ __ ] look it's all
cracked
what you do look if you don't want that
we got the lg wing my friend look at
that
whoo what am i supposed to do like call
call uh down done here we go there you
go sir
this is what you need you were getting
android today thank demon you're getting
it today
okay give me your car okay i gave you my
car
hold that hurry up hold this
okay i get my little crack card this is
funnier than i thought it would be
bro why are you wrapping your [ __ ] you
had to wrap two days ago
well how's everybody gonna know if i got
a new tag
i gotta have plastic you have the you
got the lighting
you got the you got everything yeah i
don't get this joke because i i don't
know people
that have tattoos really or if they did
get them
i wasn't there so
hey bro you heard about the [ __ ] new
playboy party albums but i'm coming out
bro
homeless better be bombers
what the [ __ ]
i gotta protect you go to a walmart in
the hood
so you're really just out here drinking
and smoking in your walmart
you even want your job yeah i'm on break
i don't give a [ __ ]
i mean she won't
[Music]
[Music]
might be next to the cereal
i don't think it's gonna be [ __ ] up
man right now
what oh gumby look at that
man [ __ ] woman
[Music]
[ __ ] get off my truck
yeah my mom's excited to get me out of
the house obviously she is man well hey
when can you start
uh-huh okay all right man
i'll see you soon huh i was a good kid i
like the suit
hey debbie could you bring in sebastian
mcelwain
hey buddy trash is right there debbie
can you bring in sebastian
hey hey man are you coming here brother
how are you doing hey
sebastian have a seat man
yeah look at you hey bill you strong huh
okay all right brother i'm just going to
cut straight to the shoes can i call you
brother
all right come on hey uh what would you
say some of your strengths are
um i'm a hard worker
[Music]
no i'm not doing anything important no
it's just some guy and i'll tell you
about it later it's pretty funny
right i gotta let you go no
no no we're talking about we're talking
about groceries man let's talk about
groceries
hey uh this is a family company and we
go off of a lot of pillars here okay
three specifically first one integrity
second sobriety
third i can't remember the third
the third uh a table 906. get the [ __ ]
out of here i'm doing an interview
these people man jesus
this gets stressful in here sometimes
i'm sorry could you pick that up for me
thanks brother
yeah anyway so sobriety is a huge one
we're gonna have you uh
take a drug test that's not a problem
been sober my whole entire life
sure about that never tried any pcp
crack meth smack
weed it's weed for sure never did drugs
never
you're drinking a beer right now it's a
beer it's legal
why the [ __ ] hey i don't i don't think
it's going to work out for us i don't
think reviving well you don't have the
same values for this
company needs and deserves are you
serious right now
yeah i gotta i i can't it's because i'm
black isn't it it's not because you're
black hey demetrius get in here
what's up bro come here look at this do
you see this skin
he's hot we hire black people all the
time this is ridiculous my mom is black
get the [ __ ] out of here what this is
are you
yo matt uh this is demetrius bro i'm not
gonna be able to make it into my shift
today
yeah i'm just i'm feeling a bit under
the weather uh
come on means it's not gonna work for me
this is the third time this week
man i got a line out the door
you you just can't come in for a little
bit i can't even come in for a little
bit bro like
i have diarrhea i have explosive
diarrhea did you say explosive diarrhea
i got something for that can you just
come in for like two hours
matt you're not listening i'm running a
fever okay
i have a 230 degree fever and diarrhea
and a slight cough okay i am not safe
for the work
environment no i can't come in and close
for 30 minutes
so you're not coming in all right don't
expect your job to be here when you get
back
[ __ ] dude [ __ ] am i hired now man
what up i just got out i'm looking for a
new phone
actually you're looking for a job
[Music]
that was kind of funny
oh [ __ ] really pretty you're really
about to be on your version though
all right bro what'd you want to get
into i know that [ __ ] man
okay that's real crazy bout to ride a
[ __ ] mr willy
they gonna [ __ ] my [ __ ] fight around
for a stemi and his taxes tell about
your sugar daddy and [ __ ] man that [ __ ]
mr willie
is handicapped bro why are you trying to
[ __ ] that [ __ ] up like that
he's [ __ ] my [ __ ] okay yeah that's a
good reason actually
man don't kill that [ __ ] man you
straight man put that [ __ ] down
that's what we need to be on this pack
[ __ ] how many times we said we were
gonna sell drugs and we did
purge time man let's go everybody get
eight dollars maybe what you talking
about
yo yo you're good yeah hey tyrell man
you're breathing hard
[ __ ] both for y'all [ __ ] i'm about to
kill this [ __ ] [ __ ] man
my baby mom's talking about that child
support again again i'm about to blow
that [ __ ] [ __ ] belly to [ __ ]
up on me
yeah but you ain't never paid [ __ ] who
shot y'all [ __ ]
i don't i've never seen the purge so i
just skipped that one
jesse what the [ __ ] why do you kill
brian like yo brian
it's pretty obvious amanda frank just
neck two milligrams of gummy bears
okay i don't i'm gonna skip this one too
because i don't know what this is
come on come on you already came down a
couple who takes service animals too
seriously
gosh she's so cute what strain is it
what strain is she
she's a hybrid oh my gosh she's so cute
how old is she
oh yeah about about six months she's
just a little baby
what do you mean i can't take gelato in
with me she's my service animal
gelato yes bro that's not a service
animal man
she may not you can't break you can't
bring a plant in here it's not a plant
okay she helps me i definitely bring in
my dog
everywhere maintain homeostasis okay
every morning with this damn neighbor
brush
oh hi hey hey bro man every morning with
this damn neighbor brush
god go tell someone
oh hi hey hey bro man it's hey in the
morning man i'm trying to sleep can you
please keep the music down yeah you
you're the guy from downstairs right
yeah of course
no [ __ ] yeah of course no problem i
gotta work as a man
i need a [ __ ] sleep keep the music
down please you know what it's off
it's off no more music all right yeah
have a good night
they never mean it they never mean it
this graveyard should kill me man oh god
[Music]
bro i thought i told you to keep the
[ __ ] music down
downstairs neighbor i swear then there's
no music then what's all this loud [ __ ]
i'm hearing
oh that that's a movie a movie bro no
[ __ ]
music or movies right now bro come on
ain't you drinking too
do you want one i i got one for you
right here dude yeah no i'm cool bro
let's head learning no more to be
drinking bro come on
cut the [ __ ] out i'm trying to sleep
you know all right i promise nothing
nothing more no more we're gonna come up
with your man i swear to god
bro i'm [ __ ] tired of this [ __ ] man
cut the music cut the movies out man
okay i don't got no music i don't got no
movies playing what's all this [ __ ] that
i'm hearing then
i don't know that's your imagination
maybe man bro i'm ready to go
i know what the [ __ ] i'm hearing no if
you got a complaint go file one
there's nothing right go fire one of you
give me that [ __ ] beer
enjoy it i got things going on here
god damn hey
sorry ladies uh you're downstairs so you
know
uh let's just get back to it you know
[Music]
why so many amazon packages go missing
oh hey what's up man what's going on
there for you um you know i'm just
making sure this package gets delivered
right
you know i'm a manager now so your
manager yeah man you always got to make
sure you know that
exactly make sure they put it up right
you know leaving it where it needs to be
okay but you're gonna get my package in
[Music]
some good [ __ ]
made you who made you do it
[Music]
hey buddy what the [ __ ] who are you what
the [ __ ] am i
who are you yeah that's right
don't remember [ __ ] huh your packages
were stolen my packages were stolen
that was close right that was fun it was
so close i was fine
oh my god these guys are kind of funny
i just i can't believe i watched all 12
or 10 in a row
i'm tired um but yeah guys do not forget
to subscribe to them
and me while you're at it um i'm trying
to hit 20 000 subscribers this month so
if you guys
wanted to help me out with that that
would be cool i'll talk to you guys
next time